I think the question of whether we
should be afraid of strong AI taking
over and squashing us like bugs because
it doesn't need us for the things that
it's doing is exactly the same question
as a fish would be afraid of big
corporations taking over and squashing
us like bugs because big corporations
are already agents they are already
intelligent agents in something they're
not sentient they borrow humans right
now for the decision-making but they do
have goals of their own that are
different from the goals of the humans
that they employ they usually live
longer and they're much more powerful
than people and it's very hard for a
person to do anything against the
corporation usually if you want to fight
a corporation you have to become some
major organization or corporation or
nation-state yourself so in some sense
the agency of an AI is going to be the
agency of the system that builds it that
employs it and of course most of the
eyes that we are going to build will not
be little room bars that clean your
floors but it's going to be very
intelligent systems corporations for
instance that will perform exactly
according to the logic of these systems
if so if we want to have these systems
built in such a way that they treat us
nicely we have to start right now and it
seems to be a very hard problem to do so
and the job loss because of automation
has several aspects on I think the most
obvious thing that we should be seeing
is if our jobs can be done by machines
that's a very very good thing it's not a
buckets of future if I don't need to
clean the street if I don't need to
drive a car for other people if I don't
need to work a cash register for other
people if I don't need to pick goods in
a big warehouse and put it into boxes
that's an extremely good thing and the
trouble that we have with this is that
right now this mode of labor that people
sell their lifetime to some kind of
cooperation or employer is not only the
way that we are productive it's also the
way we allocate resources this is how we
measure how how much bread you deserve
in this world and I think this is
something that we need to change some
people suggest that we need a universal
basic income I think it might be good to
be able to pay people to be good
which means massive public employment
they are going to be many jobs that can
only be done by people and these are
those jobs where we are paid for being
good interesting people
for instance good teachers good
scientists good philosophers good
thinkers good social people good nurses
for instance good people that raise
children good people that build
restaurants and theaters with people
that make art and for all these jobs we
will have enough productivity to make
sure that the enough bread comes on the
table the question is how we can
distribute this there's going to be much
much more productivity in our future
actually actually we already have enough
productivity to give everybody in the
u.s. an extremely good life and we
haven't fixed the problem of allocating
it how to distribute these things in the
best possible way and this is something
that we need to deal with in the future
and AI is going to accelerate this need
and I think by a large it might turn out
to be a very good thing that you're
forced to do this to address this
problem I mean if the past is any
evidence of the future it might be a
very bumpy road but who knows maybe when
we are forced to understand that
actually we live in an age of abundance
it might turn out to be easier than we
think
right now we are living in a world where
we do certain things the way we've done
them in the past decades and sometimes
like in the past centuries and we
perceive this them as this is the way it
has to be done and we often question
don't rest in these ways and so we might
think if I do work at this particular
Factory and this is how I earn my bread
how can we keep that state however can
we prevent AI from making my job
obsolete how is it possible that I can
keep up my standard of living and so on
in this world maybe this is the wrong
question to ask
maybe the correct question is how can we
reorganize a society that I can do the
things that I want to do most that I
think are useful to me and other people
that I really really want to because
there will be other ways that can how I
can get my bread made and how I can get
money or how I can get roof over my head
that are going to be more awesome and
and the way that he has now they're
going to be able to build better cars in
the tutor better houses in the future
better roads or better ways of
transporting people you're going to be
having a cleaner environment if you want
to and if you might pull it off because
we have more productivity and people who
have kind of better food better
healthcare the better way of living and
not because we get to give them jobs
that require more work and prefer them
to lean and harder they need to work
less they need to sell less of their
life time for things that they don't
want and that's actually very very good
thing but it means that we have to
change the way our current economy works
which means we have to reinvent a lot of
our labor market systems we have to
reinvent the way we distribute money and
allocate resources in society and then
that happens people have a much better
life and we can courage imagine
[Music]